divided neatly, resulting in a different number of days in the month of 30 or 31 days. 3 00: 00: 08,769 -> 00: 00: 13,219 to February - the black sheep - who only gets 28 ... except when she gets 29 and 4 00: 00: 13,219 -> 00: 00: 15,870 then year has 366 days. 5 00: 00: 15,870 -> 00: 00: 18,910 Why is this happening? 6 00: 00: 18,910 -> 00: 00: 19,640 What are the crazy universes in which years are shorter than ever? 7 00: 00: 19,640 -> 00: 00: 22,190 If we were to answer this question, we need to know what exactly is the year? 8 00: 00: 22,190 -> 00: 00: 25,610 If we pre-simplify it, it is time the Earth needs to make a full circle around 9 00: 00: 25,610 -> 00: 00: 28,320Sunc. This coincidentally coincided with the changing of the seasons. 10 00: 00: 28,320 -> 00: 00: 31,730 Now, when we draw a small diagram like this that shows the Earth's Circumference around the Sun 11 00: 00: 31,730 -> 00: 00: 35,190 it looks simple but exactly follows the Earth's rotation the country is complicated because the universe does not provide us with a suitable map to monitor the development of the situation, 12 00: 00: 35,190 -> 00: 00: 37,430.
On Earth you just see a change of seasons and an obvious way of measuring their 14 00: 00: 40,500 -> 00: 00: 45,260 it is a change to count the days that pass through the 365 day calendar.
But as soon as we start using this calendar, it slowly falls off from sync with the annuals. 16 00: 00: 49,210 -> 00: 00: 52,079 And with every year that passes the deflection is bigger and bigger. 17 00: 00: 52,079 -> 00: 00: 55,810 In the three decades the calendar will be mistaken for the whole week, and in a few hundred years the entire season 18 00: 00: 55,810 -> 00: 01: 00,100 can be mixed - what would mean that Christmas would celebrate in the middle of summer - What would be crazy. 19 00: 01: 00,100 -> 00: 01: 03,149 Why is this happening? Did we count the days wrong? Well, the calendar envisages 20 00: 01: 03,149 -> 00: 01: 08,069 the Earth's need to make a circle around the Sun is 8,760 hours. But more precisely measured 21 00: 01: 08,069 -> 00: 01: 11,479 with a stopwatch lasts longer than the one scheduled for the calendar
for about 6 hours. That's why our calendar is moving faster than the season
alternate.
so we come to the basic problem of all calendars: to day / night changes
Although simple to measure, they have nothing to do with the year.
Day and night are caused by Earth rotation around its axis. 00: 01: 30,740 -> 00: 01: 30,740 To the sun, the day is on the other side of the night. But this rotation is not 28 00: 01: 30,740 -> 00:01 : 34,009 more connected to the movement of Earth around the Sun than ballerina turning to
a truck associated with the speed of a truck.
count the time that the ballerina turned to predict the speed of the truck
can give us approximate value, but it is crazy to assume that this is the exact value.
Counting the days to keep track of the Earth's movement around the Sun is just the same, so we can not stay
surprised when the Earth does not make exactly 365 turns in one year. 34 00: 01: 50,789 -> 00: 01: 56,310 It's also irrational that although 365 days are too short, 366 is too much and still causes 35 00: 01: 56,310 -> 00: 01: 58,740 a sync in sync, only in the opposite direction. 36 00: 01: 58,740 -> 00: 02: 02,069 The resignation for this is all: a sad year. Where February gets one more day, but only 37 00: 02: 02,069 -> 00: 02: 03,439 every 4 years.
This is because we're short for a quarter of a year, so after four days 00: 02: 07,039 -> 00: 02: 09,390 we're adding one day to match.
Huzzah! The problem is resolved. 41 00: 02: 11,230 -> 00: 02: 12,540 Besides, what is not. 42 00: 02: 12,540 -> 00: 02: 15,739 spending calendar for one day every 4 years is a bit too much, and a calendar 43 00: 02: 15,739 -> 00: 02: 19,129 is still late for annual holidays one day every 100 years. 44 00: 02: 19,129 -> 00: 02: 22,459 What's fine for those who are still, but not for calendar designers who want to be
perfectly matched.
To correct this mistake every cent of the century is overwhelming. 47 00: 02: 26,739 -> 00: 02: 30,540 So that 1896 and 1904 were offensive, but 1900 did not.
It's better now, but still not ideal because the calendar is a bit too fast
1 day in 400 years. 50 00: 02: 36,000 -> 00: 02: 39,030 That's why there is an additional clause that says that if the century
divisible by 400, then it will be an offensive year. 52 00: 02: 41,879 -> 00: 02: 45,159 That way the 1900 and 2100 were not offensive, but 2000 is. 53 00: 02: 45,159 -> 00: 02: 49,180 So these three rules of error have been revealed to 1 day in 8,000 years, 54 00: 02: 49,180 -> 00: 02: 52,569 what the current calendar determines as a negligible mistake, ends the story. 55 00: 02: 52,569 -> 00: 02: 55,390 They were trying to find out if agriculture was a good business for 8000 years in the future 57 00: 02: 58,730 -> 00: 03: 01,549 Let's hope we use a much more precise calendar that measures the days. 58 00: 03: 01,549 -> 00: 03: 06,150 But you're a mathematician and an error of 0.0001 percent is unacceptable in your eyes
and must be removed.
"Poor happiness" corresponds to your universe, because even the day is not constant. Races 61 00: 03: 10,730 -> 00: 03: 14,930 are alternated in milliseconds so that shorter / longer 1 millisecond
every 100 years. Which means it's virtually impossible to make a perfect calendar 63 00: 03: 18,810 -> 00: 03: 19,969 which will last forever. 64 00: 03: 19,969 -> 00: 03: 23,090 In theory, the length of the day should be extended to be the same month - but not 65 00: 03: 23,090 -> 00: 03: 27,019 it's needed three hundred years, and our Sun expands and will eventually destroy us 66 00: 03: 27,019 -> 00: 03: 28,799 before we calculate it.
I'm sorry, I do not know how we moved from the offensive year to the inevitable
the death of all human civilization - if we of course have enough resources for the research of the universe 69 00: 03: 35,299 -> 00: 03: 37,349 (NA, SA) - but it is. 70 00: 03: 37,349 -> 00: 03: 40,409To the next 8,000 years of age will be matched with the calendar
but in an extremely complicated way.
You can learn more about orbits, different years, black holes
at Minute Physics. As always, Henry explains this very well
in new videos. See !.